let's think about straight lines you're
gonna need to draw some Oh sets of axes
we'd lead they don't have to be huge
because the things we're drawing are not
very detailed there's a straight line
let's start with normal serve axes it
kind of the promotions basic lines you
can have are actually the ones I've kind
of already lost the axes themselves okay
so if you think about the axes they
themselves are straight lines by the way
up from now on you kind of got a sense
of it when I say why I do be straight
lines right I don't mean like oh this is
a curvy line if in mathematics will they
say leaving are they beat straight so
the X and y-axis are themselves straight
lines and they each have an equation
right so let's for instance think about
the vertical axis you thought no y axis
right well what this y axis Y I can take
any value but every single point on
there
they all have the same exhale
do they not because they're all like
stacked up on top of each other and that
same x-value of course is zero right so
the equation of the y-axis is x equals
zero now by application therefore if you
have a double line that's also vertical
but not on the same spot let's draw
another one there like say this if it's
parallel it's doing the same kind of
thing I can take any value but X they
all share the same value just it's a
different thing okay so if it's
intercept is a we'd say that this
vertical line is x equals falling
exactly this new logic we've got that x
axis as well X values to take anything
but all of the Y values are the same
they're all they're all zero we're awake
Good Wife is zero which means my
vacation if you have any other
horizontal line on the graph like say up
here
and if it's p-intercept with the one
axis is the topic then of course this is
going to be like was made they are
parallel worth noting that the
horizontal lines right they both have
gradients their gradients because
they're not rising their gradients are
because here the vertical lines because
there they are kind of rising but
they're not running anywhere right yeah
it's kind of weird you might think oh
it's come on it but it's not straight up
but the thing is that we are dividing by
like rate is right over one isn't it and
they're not writing anywhere even though
I've drawn up these lines have no
thickness
okay so they literally have no time so
therefore you can't divide by zero so
these don't have a gradient
they are undefined it's not infinite the
gradient is not a fun
it's a critical indie excellent now
these of us sipping the kinds of lines
let's draw our new set of axes when you
start looking on the rest of the lines
it's just voters and they just tilt it
at different angles in a different
position that's all they are
okay so we would say after you
horizontal the vertical lines you would
say the general kind of line for general
for for whitey a line we say is just to
make sure there's a convention so we all
could be the canyon consistent length is
ax was a big wide while see okay so
where is this one our graph if I were to
draw a line let's say these
okay it's got two important features we
need to know namely x-intercept and
y-intercept right how are we going to
work out the x-intercepts what do we do
to the equation to find the x-intercept
you let y equal zero because that's the
equation like we're finding a point of
intersection right see when y equals
zero you're getting a X plus C equals
zero so when you rearrange that a little
bit you're gonna get minus C on a right
you've got to get that on it's arts and
you take the CoV downside which makes it
minus C and then you know what ax you
just 1x so you do buy it by hand in
exactly the same way what y-intercept
are you going to do
yes a trick right you bet x equals zero
this time you go b y plus c you take the
C over ya same okay now that looks a
little weird doesn't it
right because that one's okay kids
negative so today this says it's
negative but I brought it above the
x-axis why would that be what does that
imply it means that either B or C one of
them must be negative right and you can
put a survey and says that it's fairly
super general for and in horizontal
vertical lines right you then get four
other ways of wife cheating the same
kinds of like that just forms and it
just depends on what features you want
right for different ways we're doing
them all together but can you think of
what the four ways are so we can do that
what's the first way you can think of
that will name the feature most
obviously okay there's going to be quite
gradient fault
that's usually in the first one people
come up with give me another one
okay all right I heard others yeah I've
got gradient intercepts
say instead walk so sorry to me luckily
vision this equation of the line right
the four minutes in you can read off
with what point passes through and what
gradient has here you can read off what
gradient has and we're passes what what
didn't she sent it out over to the
y-axis up I heard two point
that's 3/4 right there's one more which
is one more that tells you a geometric
feature or what you baby kids mean
unusual it's not I've got general wall I
already got there there's another one
it's very uncommon on the middle it's
very similar to this one rather 2.4
which is just 2 points anywhere in space
you can have something to grate it it's
happened that's a fancy like to
intercept all right just like this and
this is like an intercept with the axis
versus a point any brain space this is
an internet with the axis sections both
of those versus two points in space okay
so what we'll do is okay
um said backsies now we'll just say max
is free
we will do it let's do gradient
intercept I think crazy
let the two
there you know what the form is this is
really achieved quite thoroughly by now
you guys are good in it but how do you
arrive at that thing okay we have
gradient and we have to intercept to
find what's you can see on what what's
the standard standard name for um the
wines except usually not always than
usually it's usually it's usually be
like that's the most common one as you
can see it will always be but we're
trying to keep it consistent so if I
have some point V let's put it there
okay if I can make a prima Pils what
senses I have a defined gradient how are
we going to get out of this that there
is well you guys know what the answer is
but how did how we did
here's what I'm going to do write
whatever equation don't know why I come
up with it it just has my every single
point on this line you agree every
single point so for example a point on
this line I'm going to call it X comma Y
right not x1 y1 as if it was an actual
value I be x + y as in all the x-values
and all their corresponding Y that is
that along this line so these guys are
variables okay now remember I've got my
intercept on there already the other
thing I knew is a gradient so how am I
gonna connect gradient to this diagram
where did gradient belong on this
diagram you can nominate your idea
okay so we've got our why's he on this
is right and we have one here okay so
how do we work out each one let's do our
listed rise first shall we
it's his vertical distance right it's
gonna be the top minus the bottom right
probably the top value is why whatever
that happens to be if the bottom value
is B right so in this case Y is is a bit
yeah give it that in the same way having
a look at run okay I'm gonna take this
further value and subtract its original
value now this is B but it's actual
coordinates are what are the coordinate
of this point it's one on the x-axis so
should be zero be immittance so here in
reading this value minus that value it's
gonna be
Thanks you came with that okay so
there's wise over one rise over run okay
but I'm defining that as some gradient
some number that you want to choose okay
that's the whole point that's a feature
I read up so now I don't have to do very
much of this do I to get my stability a
four-mile multiplied through by X right
and then I just make Y the subject if
Walla thank you happy with that